well I'm gonna be selfish and take care
of myself more which I haven't for a
decade well I would expand that to
really to everybody I'm gonna tell you
what I mean you owe it to yourself
everybody whether you've been wounded or
not right wherever you are in life
because the fact of what you just said
you got to remember this if you don't
take care of yourself you can't take
care of the other people around right
and and so you have to that's the take
care yourself you know my simple thing
and my wife knows this about me like if
I don't work out I'm I I'm not a good
I'm not I'm not the same person right no
good you know but but really if I'm not
taking care of my health then everything
else kind of starts falling and so yeah
you got to take care of yourself and if
you don't take care of yourself then you
can't take care of the people that you
care about and and so that's the duty
really and that's what I wanted to talk
about a little bit today and what I was
saying before about if you're feeling it
pull over and that's the thing like you
can't expect anything of anyone else if
you can't if if you can't show up at
work on time like why should you your
staff and if you don't take care of
yourself and then why should you expect
to take care of anyone else and we all
have support you know and I'm at no I'm
I oh no I'm hammer in this little too
hard but dude I'm I'm learning a hard
lesson here and I'm trying to avoid we
all I think have to learn it but there's
like there's you can learn it harder
than others
and I think I'm learning it the really
hard way because I am a public person
like like a private in Canada we call
them blog ins blog ins is like smithing
in the army so if blog ins is having a
rough time he doesn't have to go on the
radio and tell the world he doesn't have
to go on the Jocko podcast and tell the
world but he has to tell somebody and
that's the biggest thing you think you
think it's scary to go to a therapist
who is a trained professional like think
of a therapist like going to the rifle
range and learning from the master
sniper that's what you're doing you're
going to learn how to shoot except it's
worth it for your mind would you not go
to the range to learn from a master
sniper if you want to be a better shot
of course you fucking would Iowa I'm a
master sniper and I'd go to the range
and learn from Masterson
right now that's what a therapist or
psychiatrist or psychologist or
counselor any of them are professionals
in the mental game of life now I'm not
saying all are equal as well if you
don't like one fire them and get a
different one but start there and start
looking for the help that's available
and don't put it all on yourself and
again if you think that's embarrassing
going to a stranger which is actually
pretty easy when you actually get in the
room and start talking you find you
might they might have tell you to shut
up because there's hours up try going on
the radio or the jaakko podcast or
writing a book like you know I put out a
lot of my warts in that book too and I'm
still learning and I've got all these
resources so you know it's not it's not
it's not
no one's too proud no one's too tough